the jurgen experience so i recently saw
you on instagram posting about marcus
aurelius yes and so i want to can we
view your channel
please so
in my in the next book that i'm working
doing the recipe for the good life of
course i get into the history of all
sorts of cultures that have explored the
good life it's not as though i'm the
first guy to write about this
probably one of the topics that's
supposed been most written about
none have been as prolific as the
ancient greeks and so and so when i when
i saw your thing about marcus aurelius i
was about to write you to say well i've
come to that same realization because
so as i was doing my research for the
book
every time i would get an insight that i
thought was original to me i'd say that
[ __ ] epictetus has already said it
2000 years ago isn't that wild yeah it's
unbelievable
and so it reminds me and i want to give
him kudos on the show so you know nasim
talib is sure yeah so nassim is a good
friend of mine he's fellow lebanese and
so many years ago he was kind of egging
me teasing me saying i don't really
understand what you study in psychology
god everything that there is to know
about psychology and human nature the
ancient greeks have already covered it
and so i i mean he was just egging me on
but then many years later as i'm
preparing for this book i'm like i think
he might be right
you know we might be empirically
validating what they've already
philosophized but so so so your
you know post about marcus aurelius
really resonated with me at exactly that
same moment it's quite fascinating when
you read his his writing it's
unbelievable because he was so wise and
his
decisions for what he would concentrate
on and not concentrate on and you know
how he would accept people's flaws and
and mistakes that they'd made as if they
had never made them and this just
approach to stoicism and his
philosophy on life the greeks were
the greeks and the romans and you know
if you look at the the history of these
ancient civilizations that dominated the
world at that period of time
and just we can get
a kind of an understanding of how they
thought about things it's to me one of
the more uh amazing things about history
is to peer into the it's almost like you
have a little bit of a time machine to
peer into the mindset of these people
that were so wise thousands and
thousands of years ago and that their
words are applicable today yeah well i
mean that speaks to the universality of
the human condition right so i always
tell my students when i'm teaching about
evolutionary theory i say look you can
use cultural products as fossils of the
human mind right the human mind doesn't
fossilize but the products that is left
from human minds we can study its
contents in the same way that
paleontologists studies fossil remains
so i can i can connect to the mind of an
ancient greek poet and understand what
he's talking about as though he's
speaking today because the software
that's running his mind and mine is
identical he doesn't know what an iphone
is he doesn't know what a podcast is but
he knows about sexual longing he knows
about paternity uncertainty he knows
about sibling rivalry those are the
universal themes that are invariant
across time and place and so
one of the things that i love about
being an author is that i get to be
connected through ideas with all of
these immortal souls you know and so
it's really a beautiful
thing to to write and to create and that
the fact that i independently thought of
something that epictetus thought 2000
years ago connects me with him yes truth
it's just you developed an understanding
of human beings and of human nature and
you have deciphered
from this and extracted some truth and
it turns out other people have done the
same thing fantastic it is fantastic you
know there's a great book uh called the
um
the what is it immortality code
and it's uh brian murray rescue who has
he's gone through uh
ancient greek culture
and uh all of the uh
ulucidian mysteries and looked into all
of their rituals and tried to figure out
like what was going on and one of the
things that they've done is
going over pottery
and finding that there's remnants of
psychedelic substances in these in these
pottery jars
and so these wine jars
these jugs these as pottery they found
that they were
imbibing in wine that was dosed with
lysergic acid wow so they had different
kinds of ergot and different kinds of
things that would produce psychedelic
states so all of these you know like
when when people would go there to learn
and when people would go to have these
uh ritualistic experiences they were
tripping right and this is the
birthplace of democracy this is the
birthplace of a lot of these uh thinkers
these great thinkers of uh you know that
age
and of course uh roman emperors uh
forbade it and they outlawed it and they
in in the book they sort of detail how
it uh migrated to other countries and
you can find the same remnants in the
pottery in these other countries and you
can literally pat
you could track the path of their escape
from these areas where they were more
restrictive and and and trying these
ritualistic uh experiences in other
places but yeah it's the the immort it's
the immortality key or code
key the immortality key it's an amazing
book really really and brian was on the
podcast and because of him being on the
podcast harvard has opened up a field of
study wow and in that particular
area where they're looking at
psychedelic substance use in ancient
greece because it's irrefutable now
because of the residue now they now have
scientific evidence they have residue
that shows that they were most certainly
flavoring their wine with this stuff
that's another thing that i didn't know
i always thought wine was wine it was
fermented fruit it's not their wine they
would always add things to they
constantly added stuff to their wine
their wine was never just wine their
wine was most of the time wine with
other things and oftentimes psychedelic
substances like ergot mixed in with the
wine